centre d'entraînement des girondins on
l'a vu sur la chaîne officielle de
l'équipe
il est comme chez lui théo c'est le
retour du soleil attendu ce mercredi
après midi avec des températures
maximales avec atteindront les à 19°
entraînement ce mercredi matin pour les
hommes de francis gillot qui prépare la
36e journée
comme il était grillé pour revenir sur
france 3 clément s'est déguisé en qatari
patron du psg 2006 il n'aura d'autre pas
les moyens de peser sur la décision des
actionnaires
alors on ne sait pas vers vous va
avancer le gouvernement attaque où se
trouve le garde comme on me communiquent
que pour sa dernière incruste de la
semaine clément était à la bourre ça lui
arrive du coup bah il a été obligé de
s'incruster tout juste à la sortie de sa
douche en plein direct dans une émission
politique sur une chaîne régionale
voilà c'est une association s'est
extrait d'un petit film c'est une
association qui propose qui vous propose
d'accueillir des étudiants des lycéens
alors qu'est ce que je disais
vous